What's up movie fans?
Do you enjoy wowing your friends with your
second-to-none movie knowledge?
You might know every James Bond actor in chronological
order, you might know which year every movie
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe was released,
and you might even know how many kills Freddy
Krueger made in his multiple Nightmare on
Elm Street appearances, but what about all
that lesser known movie trivia from behind
the scenes?There are a lot of facts about
movies that might just take you by surprise
- and that's what this video is all about.
Here's our latest edition of twenty rapid
fire behind the scenes movie facts...
Suicide Squad
Jai Courtney - who is playing Captain Boomerang
is Suicide Squad - quite famously said that
he would never appear in a comic book movie.
However, he changed his ming when he learned
that David Ayer was to direct and produce
the 2016 DC offering.
Underworld: Blood Wars
Although the official title for the fifth
installment in the Underworld franchise is
now Underworld: Blood Wars, the working title
of the movie was actually Underworld: Next
Generation.
Ali
Will Smith actually turned down the role of
Muhammad Ali in Ali initially, but after the
former boxer himself gave Smith a call telling
him he was the only actor good-looking enough
to play him, the Fresh Prince of Bel-Air star
changed his mind.
Iron Man
During the final press conference in Iron
Man, Tony Stark reveals that he is the titular
hero to the world's press.
The extras in the scene were told that it
was a dream sequence to prevent them from
spreading spoilers.
Hulk
In 2003's Hulk movie, the Green Goliath was
generated using CGI.
To show the movie's actors where he would
be standing in any given scene, a cardboard
cutout - nicknamed "Elvis Presley on a stick"
by the cast and crew - was put in place.
The Incredible Hulk
In 2008's Hulk reboot - The Incredible Hulk
- the scene in which a drop of Bruce Banner's
gamma-irradiated blood falls through three
factory stories into a bottle took visual
effects artists more than a year to construct.
Superman Returns
In the plaza of the Daily Planet building
in Superman Returns, there's a sign that says
"Shuster Square."
This is a reference to Joe Shuster, who was
one of the co-creators of the original Superman
character.
Man of Steel
In Man of Steel, Russell Crowe became the
second Oscar winner to portray Jor-El, after
Marlon Brando in the Christopher Reeve Superman
movies.
Coincidentally, whilst going by the name "Rus
Le Roq" in the 1980s, Crowe recorded a song
called "I want to be like Marlon Brando".
War of the Worlds
When Tom Cruise's Ray Ferrier arrived home
covered in the ashy remains of the Tripod's
first victims in War of the Worlds, the horror
he expressed upon that realisation was influenced
by September the 11th survivor stories.
Avatar
Most of the animal noises in the hugely successful
Avatar were recycled from another massively
successful movie - Jurassic Park.
The T-Rex and Raptor noises in particular
are used a lot - for the horse-like Pale and
the Thanator, respectively.
The Fighter
Ultimately, boxing movie The Fighter was directed
by David O. Russell, but the movie's star,
Mark Wahlberg, initially sent the script to
Martin Scorsese personally in the hope that
he would take the helm.
Titanic
After finding out the she would have to be
naked in front of Leonardo DiCaprio in Titanic,
Kate Winslet opted to break the ice when the
pair first met.
She did so by flashing him.
Jason Bourne
Jason Bourne will be the the first Bourne
film not to have the franchise's trademark
title format of The Bourne something-something.
Had it followed the usual format, in the order
of the books, it would have been called The
Bourne Betrayal.
The Purge: Election Year
The Purge: Election Year will be the first
Purge movie to be a direct story sequel, as
it continues exploring the life of Frank Grillo's
Sergeant Leo Barnes, while Edwin Hodge will
become the only actor to have appeared in
all three movies in the franchise.
Ghostbusters
Emma Stone outright turned down the opportunity
to star in the new Ghostbusters movie.
She liked the script, but didn't want to commit
to another potential franchise so soon after
appearing in The Amazing Spider-Man and its
sequel.
Step Brothers
The fake testicles that Will Ferrell's Brennan
Huff rested on Dale's drumkit in Step Brothers
were worth around $20,000 and were presented
to Ferrell as a wrap present when filming
was completed.
The Hangover
In The Hangover, "Stu's Song" and "Three Best
Friends" - the songs performed by Ed Helms
and Zach Galifianakis respectively - were
both improvised by the actors.
Star Trek Beyond
Star Trek Beyond will be the first Star Trek
film to be shot primarily in Vancouver in
British Columbia and not in Hollywood.
All existing sets, including those of the
USS Enterprise, have rebuilt from scratch
in a large studio in Vancouver.
Star Wars: The Force Awakens
Carrie Fisher and Mark Hamill collectively
lost 85lbs to get in shape for Star Wars:
The Force Awakens, with Fisher losing 35lbs
and Hamill losing 50lbs.
Justice League
After rumours about the potential of the likes
Darkseid and Brainiac appearing, it has recently
been revealed that Steppenwolf - a character
from a deleted scene in Batman v Superman:
Dawn of Justice - will actually be the main
villain of 2017's Justice League.
Thanks for watching our latest list of 20
rapid fire behind the scenes movie facts.
Did you know about any of these?
Which other great movie facts do you know
of?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.